nous allons vous conter l'histoire des
aventures des aventures nous allons vous
conter l'histoire les aventures de
renard
[Musique]
son nom
dans le
non
[Musique]
et
qu'attends-tu au bord de cette route une
charrette remplie de harengs biafrais
comme on le sait tu je l' ai aperçu à
une lieue de là j'ai couru et me suis
posté ici je vais m'étendre sur la route
qu'en faisant le mort
les marchands de poissons lorsqu'ils
arriveront prennent mois a ravi d'avoir
une peau à si bon compte
me jetteront dans leur charrette là
j'aurai tout mon temps pour me remplir
le ventre de leur pêche
une fois repu ne me restera plus qu'à
sauter à terre et par saint leu voilà
une excellente idée ne voudrais tu pas
me laisser tenter ma chance je suis
d'accord pour vous laisser ma place mais
à une seule condition c'est que dans
cette affaire vous n'oubliez pas et que
vous emportez quelques uns rang pour moi
se produire au nord de nice nous a si
justement la charrette qui approche
j'entends le bruit des roues
allongez-vous vite
[Musique]
regarde d'abord on dirait un loup ouais
galère bien mort attends je vais voir
[Musique]
en
l'idée qu'il fait semblant et qu'il veut
nous jouer le même tour que ce maudit
goupil tu vois bien s'il est mort
il est bien mort je te dis
attends un peu tu vas voir
[Musique]
on
ans
[Musique]
où